before the president got the virus he
planned to campaign tomorrow in
wisconsin
which is in the middle of a worsening
covid crisis that state is one of
29 where coronavirus cases are on the
rise
yesterday wisconsin reported its largest
one-day increase in new cases
more than 2 800. meg oliver looks at how
wisconsin's hospitals
are wrestling with the challenge
inside the icu at aspires hospital in
wausau wisconsin the number of covid
patients is growing fast
their health system saw a 30 percent
jump in coveted patients in a single day
according to ceo matthew haywood this is
just the beginning of us having two or
three months of this
and we've got to get through this 82
percent of all hospital beds in the
state are full
after new covet cases more than doubled
over the last
month milwaukee county hospitals may
need to use this
alternate care facility at the nearby
state fairgrounds if trends continue
right now we can't live like we're back
to the way
things used to be we can't afford to act
like things are
business as usual as cases rise across
the midwest
ohio governor mike dewine announced the
results of a large antibody study on
thursday
it revealed millions of ohioans likely
remain
vulnerable to infection and that herd
immunity is a long way away
so what we have to do is hang in there
we got to keep this virus low
and we wait for the vaccine to hit as
several vaccine manufacturers continue
critical work in phase 3 trials some
participants have developed side effects
including 53 year old lisa majeski what
have the side effects been like
after the first injection i just had
some mild body aches for about half the
day
and i just took some pain medication and
i felt better and after the second one
it was about a whole day of a low grade
fever and more severe body aches
and i took some more advil and i felt
fine the next day
any regrets no none at all
this is one of the testing sites for the
moderna vaccine at hackensack university
medical center
this week we learned the ceo doesn't
expect the vaccine to be widely
available until next spring
and on thursday the ceo of pfizer told
employees they will continue to move at
the speed of science with their vaccine
and not about a political pressure to
move faster tony
mike thank you very much well certainly
a lot to take in this morning
as we wake up to the news of the
president and the first lady testing
positive i'm stuck with the remark from
dr david agus looking at the numbers
that
in his age bracket with this diagnosis
there's about a 10
chance he could have serious
complications and we and as we've seen
with other world leaders boris johnson
in particular
very ill well initially he wasn't
initially everything seemed fine and
then he took a turn
so this this as we've pointed out over
the last months
this virus acts differently with
everybody
well it's just another indication about
how this virus does not discriminate no
no
no one is immune from it if the
president of the united states can get
it
who is that protected and that well
covered and that he gets it
it says a lot i hope that they will be
listening at the white house to what
major garrett was saying about
transparency
you really got to be very clear about
when this happened how this happened
and who had who has he been in contact
with yeah that's a lot of people
it is and at the scope of this how far
is not yet cleared
yeah the world is watching and wondering
so many questions still remain yeah we
don't know
as boris johnson said this could go
either way he said as he came out of
intensive care right
we'll be following whatever direction it
goes